you want to have a good time tonight
[Music]
[Music]
going up
[Music]
is
[Music]
if
[Music]
expensive
[Music]
[Music]
sense of danger
one from
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
rain rain
hey everyone welcome to moses and
friends i am your host moses storm this
is the show where we take all of our
favorite people here at team coco and we
put them up
live in your living room it is march
which means it's international women's
month and it's so important
for shows to completely stop down to let
you know that they're doing the bare
minimum
of woke um i like to trip all over
myself to pat myself on the back to say
that we have
for the first time in this show's
history i think we've been on the air
for 41 years now but for the first time
we're gonna have
a woman on so buckle up
it's gonna be different usually if
you've seen the show before
it's usually six of my boys and we are
all
loudly talking over each other tage
taint
tank dax boy ashley and we just watched
the cut scenes from cyberpunk
and we play dubstep covers of hey there
delilah
and we talk about has cancelled culture
gone too far uh no we have three
women on they happen to be women they're
just three funny comics i wanted to talk
to
the first comedian to bring to the stage
of your screen
is uh is on a quite literally right now
i think on the set
of uh upload which is original amazon
series by the creators of the office
zanab johnson hey moses
is that what you're shooting right now
can you say yeah i'm in vancouver right
now
and i'm not actually on set but i am
uh next door in the production office in
one of their spaces
because the wi-fi in my trailer sucked
how is it one shooting something
in a lockdown because a lot of the fun
of being on set is that it's
more social than stand up it's getting
to hang out with everyone but now
there's this almost
weird protective coat on everything you
know what
kovit i thought that covid was going to
make the like day-to-day things really
sort of
annoying um i thought it was going to
add a lot of business
to the already businessy things you have
to do
and it doesn't like you get pretty used
to it i have one of my masks
right next to me so i'm still used to
putting this on and off
um it's nothing the thing that's like um
you know can cause like anxiety is in
vancouver you get like zones
and the zones define like how often you
get tested
so you know there's different zones for
different people which is some
weird future [ __ ] of like you're a group
a
and it's like i want to be a yeah no it
totally feels i am legend
it totally feels like the beginning of
the end
yeah i think the travel ban really helps
you know like
the us and i love the us but the u.s was
like
we don't care come and go as you please
you know
and canada is still not like that when i
first got here i had to do a 14-day
quarantine and they were serious
like calling me every single day sending
emails i had to check in
the neighbors like the moment i opened
the door for instacart the neighbors
were also out there like
we dare you to take one foot out that
door
i even did a virtual fitting where they
had all the clothes delivered to my
apartment
and i was on the phone with a covet
operator from the government
and she heard the wardrobe stylist on a
zoom call
and she was like hold on a second is
that someone else in your background
it doesn't say that you've traveled with
anyone and i was like relaxed lady
it's zoom you're hearing
yeah no one has that terrible robot
voice of zoom audio cutout
yeah i mean they take i know people that
have gotten the full fine i mean there's
a hundred and sixty thousand dollar
fine yeah this person was doing like two
lines on something
so wait you know they gotta find yeah
and they they
actually in vancouver they're serious
about it
yeah they're they're serious about it
they saw someone
go to a grocery store that was on a set
that shall not be named
paramount plus network and then here
it's just like
wear your mask anywhere on your face and
then that's fine
i mean some states have removed the mask
mandate at this point i like the mask
that you have it's the one for actors so
it doesn't mess up
your hair so it's essentially it goes
around your neck right
it's a trough it feels like you should
put food in there
and then just throughout the day eat
your way out i love it because it's
always like a button to a conversation
you know how we used to be able to hang
up flip phones
whenever i've made a point at the end of
the point i'm like and i'm done
it's very satisfying and i like how you
were talking to that person with your
mask down the entire time
[Laughter]
just spraying kobe kovetkovic no more
coding
i'm not a germaphobe at all but it's
hard when they keep showing us these
very disturbing graphics of like here's
how much
spray comes off of someone and then like
how are we gonna cope after this
if you and i are talking and i'm just
gonna be thinking about these computer
graphics of just
my stuff coming off oh i'm never going
back to normal i'm standing six feet
apart from everybody i'm wearing a mask
everywhere i don't care this is a new
normal
i i know what spit does now no more
wet handshakes with people no i don't
want to do that i definitely don't want
to hug you
i've seen how many people protest about
hand washing like i gotta wash my hands
again i'm
like oh my god i'm never coming to your
house again
next i gotta wipe my butt you should
wanna do that just for you
but is it nice to just be back around
people and socializing and essentially
have an excuse
under the guidelines of like i'm working
yeah it feels really good to be back at
work i mean we
you know this we all like stand up to go
dive
you know so for me just even as a
creative person
it feels like i'm finding that i'm
having so much fun on set
and i'm i'm not afraid to try things and
i think it's because
i'm missing the performance of stanza
and so now every time i get in the scene
i'm like i got
jokes because you just do it how it's
written i'm like but i got jokes
i got joke if you can get a laugh from a
cashier at a grocery store
oh sat for the week yeah i think one of
the last things that
i did like one of the like second to
last-ish big events
is you and i were in chicago and we we
did those team
shows for the nba all-star game
unwittingly
hosting a super spreader event
unknowingly unknowingly
unknowing i saw photos pop up and like
how iphone makes you feel bad and
there's like memories from last year i'm
just looking at all the people i'm like
oh
no but that was such a great way to go
out
right if we if you have to choose what
your last kind of event was going to be
before a lockdown like
that was amazing right that was a fun
show it wasn't like i did the flappers
yoo-hoo room
yeah no 6am on a sunday my hotel i went
up in my like every morning every night
i was seeing professional nba players
for me i'm like this
is this is the way this is pregame a
lockdown
yeah and it was nice to not be like
usually if it's a comedy festival
there's a lot of pressure on comedian
this is nice because like we're the side
thing we're like the side of that
everyone's here for the nba
and if they're too drunk to be in that
game they come heckle us at this show
yeah you've been doing your your podcast
just friends
is that how you're keeping up with
performing just talking in front of
people are you trying to do these
outdoor or even zoom shows i do two
podcasts so i do honesty with z
um which is just me and i rant about the
world oh that's
great and just friends is another
podcast that i do with another comedian
and that's like relationship so we talk
all relationship
stuff we talk about everything marriage
being single sex we answer questions
it's fun you guys saw the live one you
did on sunday i was watching live
and people had questions have you
noticed the questions i've gotten a
little weirder as people have had
less time to date and more time to spend
alone
yes i don't know they're almost like too
too much to the point they don't coat
them at all
i think also too you have a lot of
people who when they're talking to
comedians they really try and jazz up
their questions
you know like they really try to write
their best
joke but the reality is you see a lot of
people are lonely like people answer
their own question
in the question like this guy cheated on
me four times but he made me laugh the
other day should i be with him
it's like you know what you have the
answer
yeah you know you wrote the answer down
i'm like girl he did not make you laugh
this is a pandemic you looking for
something funny
like everything is right yeah your list
of like would never has
severely gone down exactly exactly
so season two of upload is coming tbd
yeah season one is available on amazon
right now of course are the two great
podcasts or at least great names
i wanted to name my podcast tab people
said it doesn't make any sense
you did it talks to zainab and she just
tells him the truth
yeah it's easy we could switch it all
right well thank you thank you for chat
with us
thanks for having me you can stick
around all right my next guest you know
her from her news special on netflix
it's a one-man show it's a special it's
so much
more it's called nate natalie palomidas
thank you
for being here moses hey first
candlelit interview this looks like
you're about to tell all
i sure am even without the candle i
would i would just spill my whole guts
whatever you want to ask me
i think you can relate to this a lot of
our stuff has to do with the audience
and being able to in your case
physically touch them
yes get up in their face a lot of the
hee-hee-ha-has are from oh my god she
touched that man
i know that's my whole shtick and now i
can't touch
anybody both my solo shows are just me
like
you know swapping spit with people and
grabbing their knockers etc etc you know
and you too you know yeah i mean i get a
lot
much more backlash for grabbing knockers
but um
you gotta ask yeah no it is like i
talked to the audience and i think if
you're a comedian that's always doing
like
one-liners you don't need it then you're
fine you're able to roll into this but
to not
have the live feedback oh man
i was worried that your show was not
going to translate to
a special and it really did because it
is like exactly what we're saying it is
the live
aspect of being in the room me
personally i was like i hope she just
knows me too good that she doesn't call
on me oh
um yeah are you calling you did it no
were you there were you at the taping
not at the taping no i
think i've been to three of the shows
when you were workshopping the show
oh my gosh thanks for coming i remember
very
uh very every time
i think of you i think about this bit
that you did with yarn or you're like
making a
sweater with the audience or something
is this accurate
yeah i remember it very well but then i
was like do i remember it very well but
that that's how i remember
you whenever i think moses i think
making a sweater
the yarn guy the yarn guy that's cat boy
uh speaking of bits i cannot do in the
lockdown it's i'm connected to every
audience member
via a rope and then they can pull me
wherever and i try to do like a physical
bit or whatever and then they're
they're essentially like a puppet to
control manipulating
it's genius it's genius genius bit
beautiful physical comedy
but not every venue appreciates uh
big physical and even prop comedy
um do you have any stories of venues
that were mad because i think about that
now of like oh when you watch a show
like some some stagehead has to clean
that up
yeah well you know i always try to be
very hands-on with my cleanups and try
to help like the stagehands you know but
that
sometimes doesn't always uh you know
make them less annoyed but they're
always pretty nice i remember
at ucb franklin which they've always
been very supportive there anyhow but i
did i flooded the stage so
in the netflix special i'm in a bathtub
with the shower
and but in the live show that i just did
myself diy i just used a camping shower
with a baby pool
um underneath it and this particular
show at ucb
i didn't pull the baby pool fully
underneath the shower
and i just flooded the hole underneath
of the stage
and the artistic director was very nice
she was just like
hey you know you flooded the stage if
you do the show here again
you gotta make sure that the pool is
catching the water
and so i was like that's that's fine
that's fair and also i just i i do
cringe because nothing like kills the
bit then like apologizing for it
i know i know yeah but they're super
sweet
is it something that you think about now
when you're workshopping something of
like oh i'm gonna have to tour with this
so maybe i can't
well i mean i've seen you breathe fire i
was gonna say breathe fire but you've
done that yes
in a very small venue that is made if
like
the virgil is like if you ask the fire
department to build an example of a fire
hazard
it's low ceilings the dustiest curtains
and the curtains hang low too they hang
real low yeah so
this is probably like a dickish way to
go about
doing my stuff but i kind of operate
with a
apologize later kind of attitude
uh which you know probably
is not the best way you know maybe it's
like an [ __ ] way to go about doing
things and like if i had caught the
theater on fire
that would have [ __ ] set like i
didn't i didn't ask the producers if i
could do that
right but if you did ask them they
wouldn't let you do it yeah
i've ripped down entire curtain back
back rod of a curtain you did hanging on
that i've broken the clock on stage
that looked expensive
uh that was the portland helium
and then it was at the kennedy center
and it was like older people
and it's like a 6 p.m show and i had the
rope sweater thing that you're talking
about
yes and uh i i took someone out like it
went across her
her face like that like a rope burn oh
no
and i went back and they were like oh
they were she was cool about it
and then i went backstage to kind of
like say thank you to everyone that ran
the venue and kind of get like my pat's
on the back because it went well
yeah i just overheard them before i went
to the tech room they were like
what the hell was that
what the hell and i told him not to
climb on that stuff and i was just like
oh it didn't feel cool it didn't feel
like
i'm an artist it just felt bad for them
yeah
they're like what the [ __ ] oh my god
actually one time
so me and courtney perroso do this bit
where i play a dolphin trainer and she
plays a dolphin
and that'll be that's like yeah that'll
be they have this toxic relationship
and at the end of the bit she's sick of
him and so
i'm dangling a fish in front of her for
her to eat her treat
and she grabs it out of my hand and
starts beating me with the fish
so we're doing this show in edinburgh
scotland
have you you were no you told me to do
it but i i
i was gonna do it the 22. you were gonna
do it the 2020.
yes exactly okay i remember this but you
were the one that was pushing me to do
it so essentially you get to do your
show every night
for 30-ish days yeah exactly i think you
would kill it
anyway uh i was just there visiting
in 2019 and we were doing like a a bit
on a lineup show
and uh it was a midnight show
and everything in scotland closes at
like four o'clock or whatever
you know it's the height of the summer
there i go to the fishmonger at like
four o'clock
as late as i could to get this fish for
the bit
and it's just sitting in my backpack all
day you know
i think maybe in some ways it made the
bit a little more
punchy it made it a little bit more
effective it gave it like another kind
of factor that it
smelled just like rank
and when she beat me with the fish that
night and we
ended up going they went ran way over we
ended up going up at like 2 a.m
so this fish has been sitting in my
backpack scotland's summer since 4 p.m
it's 2 a.m she beats me with it fish got
to go flying everywhere all over the
theater and just like
is this a bigger fish if it's got guts
like what are we talking about yeah
[Music]
yeah you could hold it up in a photo
scottish mackerel you know i think it's
a good
like 10 11 inches at least yeah
yeah and it's just you know we were
apologizing profusely afterwards because
the
the theater just reeked of fish and
everybody
does their shows in there like the next
day
all throughout the day and they were
doing everything they could
like blowing fans out the theater and uh
you know spraying febreze everywhere but
it didn't quite
resolve the issues it never went away
and you want it to go away you go back
in you're like let me smile it's
probably
fine yeah it doesn't leave yeah
you get it you get it is there an
entertainer that
informed the way you perform today is
there something you watch where you're
like i didn't know you could do that
because sometimes i watch your stuff and
i'm like oh i didn't know
you could do that and it just pushes me
in a
in a direction to to experiment more to
try different things
oh thanks moses i think i would say the
same thing about you to be honest like
whenever
i watched your cat guy i was like whoa i
think brent weinbach was actually the
first person i saw
in john daly doing the drunk christmas
tree
yeah i was actually interning at conan
summer 2011
and i just went to like ucb and
john daly was doing his sapity tappity
drunk christmas tree and my mind was
blown
i was like whoa you can like just go
be a character and like interact with
people and just be [ __ ] dumb
and then i saw brent weinbach also at
ucb
and he was like doing some weird [ __ ]
bit where he was like grinding on people
in the audience not not actually
touching them you know but
in their face and i was just like whoa
these guys are weird
and um they don't give a [ __ ] so
nate you uh he's on netflix right now
the response has been great it's been
cool to see people
see what everyone has seen for so many
years of you doing your own thing
carving out your own lane and now people
are sharing it and it seems like it's
doing pretty well
thanks moses i think people like it and
like you said i was also concerned that
it wouldn't
you know and then you know cut some bits
for time which are also like
you know just like kills you inside but
yeah
i think all in all you know i i feel
like a lucky girl
you know it's like so cool and um
just to have it out there
[Music]
is awesome and i can't yeah it's it's
crazy
it's crazy to go from like some black
box theater to like
on netflix people in uh you know chile
can watch it and stuff like that how
cool is that you know
the chilean market for you has been
insane
he's hailed you as a deity there it's
been
incredible i blew up in chile i don't
know what's going on but the i get a lot
of dms from people in uh chile
you can say one thing to your chile fans
we got a lot in the comments right now
chile is going off they actually want
you to get involved in politics like
they said pick a side know if that means
anything to you
i say uh no comment right now comment
right now
ah not comment right now um every minute
i wish i knew how to say that in spanish
um but yeah no comment aura and uh
come back to me uh later
later rewatch the special thank you
natalie uh hopefully you can stick
around for a little bit
after but uh nate is on netflix right
now
highly recommend it thank you moses my
next guest is a very funny comedian from
the bay
area she's been featured in the book we
had a little real estate problem
the unherald story the native americans
in comedy
please welcome the very funny jackie
khali
that's a great name thank you appreciate
it yeah hi
how are you doing this is my first time
meeting you
you've seemed like an early adapter to
zoom comedy right away you were on the
zoom comedy train you adjusted right
away oh yeah totally
invested in a real microphone got a
little ring light
started producing shows back in april so
it'll be a year anniversary which is
who knew who knew i don't think i would
do it if you would have told me a year
ago that it was going to be this long
like
no i'll i'll end it i'm going to end
this
i had no idea and i remember just it was
my birthday was the end of march last
year and i thought okay
i'm jealous of everyone who has a summer
birthday because we're going to be on
the other end of this
oh yeah i just was naive and i'm happy
that i didn't know a thing
that we'd be doing zoom comedy for a
year people would have lost it
if we would have told them it's a year
yeah i was like maybe may could you
imagine
no it was terrible we had a live show we
were producing and we
i think it was like the a little bit
after like maybe it was the third week
of march
and we thought we probably people are
starting to cancel shows but they're
people like
who cares it's not a big deal it's a
other country thing
and uh we ended up postponing it and
saying we'll be back in april
and uh yeah that was the last post
so here we are last show i did i was on
stage in pittsburgh
and it didn't go that well because it
was like part of like people were
everything was shutting down that day
and the whole room smelled like bleach
and i walked up the stage and i was like
you know what
there's always next show oh and then
there wasn't
there was no show for an entire year
and now it's today do you feel like you
got it in was it a fun set
was it no it didn't go it wasn't like i
bombed but it wasn't like a knock out of
the park because it was the day
it was like right after the nba had shut
down uh you do
morning radio to promote your show and
the morning radio show host tested
positive
for govid he didn't cancel and the staff
was worried that just like the
bleach in the air was very eerie not the
best
element for comedy no it didn't go great
and i was like there's always tomorrow
i'm booked on my first outdoor show uh
next month exciting
i was reached out to six months ago and
someone said hey i want to get you on
this show
here are the options and i was like
let's do 2021 hopefully things will be
better by then
yeah so she hit me up and said hey are
we still on for next month and i was
like oh my god that was six months ago
so we'll see i'm i don't i'm just
prepared to just
talk as i like to write on stage and so
i'm just excited for that opportunity
like i've done
material and stuff on zoom shows but i
actually do crowd work on
zoom oh hey you got a cool background
dude you know yeah
so i'm just excited to play with people
and and hopefully they respond i don't
know what they do out there
anymore hard work has also gotten a
little dicey i've done zoom crowd work
and i'm like what
look at this guy's got so much stuff in
his van are you living in that van he
was like yeah
i lost him and i was like oh god i lost
my job moses i was here to laugh about
it thanks for the reminder
i was like let's hold on let's put his
venmo in the chat just trying to
bail immediately if you want to send him
a few bucks unless that's pandering i'm
sorry
yeah it is you don't know what people
are going through so there's no more
like look at this guy's dumb shirt
because this is the last shirt that my
father wore
before he went to the hospital like
jesus
oh yeah and then that's the thing too
you're going to have comics on your show
who've lost people who want to work it
out
in your show and it's fresh and new the
loss
you know and so that's also a whole new
territory that i don't think any of us
had experienced but it's
it's happened seen it on a couple of
shows uh so then you tried to go on the
dating apps then
oh my god i did and it was a [ __ ] show
yeah i
i thought okay i want to connect let's
see and i i did the hinge and
i've had been doing tinder but tinder's
like just kind of
it's just a wasteland not that hinge is
much better it's the same dude here's
the thing it's the same dudes
on hinge and tinder it's just their
hinge profile has pictures of their
nieces and nephew to let them know that
they're serious like i don't know
it's the same dude like i literally
would see the same guys and go oh
okay um it was weird i i did
dates and they look like this basically
you're on like a zoo
yes that's outdoor patio in masks
i did a couple of outdoor social
distance dates with one dude but like
i got onto the apps and was just trying
to like first
gauge i was just trying to gauge like
all right are you worth
me potentially exposing myself like let
me do an initial interview
and see if you're not a murderer and
then like maybe you've got a personality
you know but uh
yeah there are a couple of like really
bad calls where i was like okay one dude
was watching
um football he was like all the raiders
are playing so anyways
and just kept looking like off the
screen and i was like um
i think you're watching a game like
maybe we don't need to do this
no no it's cool it's fine it's fine it's
fine so anyway i'll hold on a second
and i was just like what the [ __ ] what's
here you clearly have nothing later you
have nothing to do
like can you i don't know i it was just
stevie r is a thing
yeah that's uh that's brutal i mean it
was brutal
it sounds romantic it sounds like i know
we're gonna see terrible romantic
comedies about like
you know lockdown at first sight or
whatever but
it is something about just being a human
that there is
communication that happens that is
non-verbal
that is right around someone feeling it
and it's very hard
to build a connection that way because
someone could just be nervous
because they're looking at like i never
i'm on a date and have to look at my own
face the entire time
exactly i did like have one video call
with a guy
that i thought was cool we had we had
been communicating through text for a
while and finally we made time for a
call
and then he answers the phone and is
like whispering and i was like what
and i was like are you on a plane he's
like uh i'm on a bus this fall was on a
greyhound and i was like why
we set a time and place for this to
happen and then he basically was like i
live in reno nevada
and i was like you said san francisco it
was just like i was like okay
every every weirdo was out
yeah he's going every weirdo third
family
exactly what's the worst line you've
gotten like the worst like
opening line because they try to find
that like i want to catch your attention
but it can sound
insane moses there's so many awful
things i think the one thing that caught
me the most off guard
was one guy who was like hold on a
second that's my daughter and i was like
uh
and he had an unproven line well we had
had our
our first call together and he was like
hang on a second i have to switch over
to my daughter and there was no
indication this person had kids
and then during the first minute and a
half discovered he had
multiple kids and i was like okay this
man
probably didn't put any truth on this
profile so i should probably go now
um but yeah that there's just terrible
it's just bad i i hate i wish i could be
more positive and it just doesn't work
yeah it doesn't work which means after
this is going to be
festival i'm sex it's going to be
rabbits so many people doing sex on each
other all this pen
weird sex too i'm so excited moses i was
like all right give me that [ __ ]
vaccine
right right here right here okay no i
i'm it's it's pent up man and it's funny
because it's spring and i'm telling you
we're animals at the end of the day and
if there's anything that we've become
close with it's our animalistic
primalistic natures
like during the last year survival all
these things
and so i feel like uh oh spring's
happening uh-oh
i can just i can feel it in the air and
i am excited i have a group of friends
we're all going to go out and just
be seen we're going to wear masks and be
responsible human beings because
that's how we've gotten it this far but
uh yeah
so excited for spring and summer
yeah every joke has to start with like
i'm single
i'm single i've been thinking about
darfur like you have to start doesn't
matter what the topic is
i hate to be that person now i was like
i never wanted to be this comic
and i'm letting people know hey yeah i'm
excited to just meet people because you
know comics like
we feel vibes we feel energy we have
that sensitivity
and you can't accomplish that over a
video chat or like a facetime or a zoom
so i'm just excited to like meet people
and just like
see what they're about and i don't know
we'll see it's going to be fun dating
this year
i'm excited guys she's she's upset she's
looking guys gals it's just anyone
backpack gals
so jackie when's this outdoor show when
can people uh
see you if someone's in the bay area
yeah it's actually half moon bay
of all places uh but that's where
they're do they've been doing outdoor
shows out there
for a while before i let you go i want
to bring everyone else back on to the
show
one year in lockdown has anyone actually
become a better person
i have took inventory and i have not
become a better person i didn't learn
spanish i didn't write something
incredible
has anyone done anything or can i feel
good about myself
i think i did one thing that is really
uncommon during a pandemic i froze my
eggs
oh that's great prosperity and just
no one brushing you yeah and i figure
maybe a couple of years from now i get a
good price for them on the black market
[Laughter]
i did a 20-day water fast yeah i don't
think you should do that did you feel
good
actually right at the beginning of
lockdown i found out i had lyme disease
and i was trying to find out for the
longest time what was wrong with my ass
yeah yeah and uh i read that it
totally eradicates lime from your body
so i was like i'm doing this
didn't work at all no it made me feel
worse it was really bad but for some
people you know i guess it works was
there a day that
that was like a a wally hit like around
day nine i think in fast where you start
hallucinating or you start i think like
not feeling hungry
day 17 around day four you don't feel
hungry but like the first
week i was like this is awesome i have
so much energy and like i'm not hungry
and then day 17 i was like [ __ ] dude and
i just kept watching a bunch of mukbang
videos and master chef
it just made you more hungry watching
the mukbang where people just like
gorge themselves it like satisfied me
jackie have you done anything
have you learned a new skill at all have
you picked up a musical instrument
well i've played the guitar before and
then got written and forgot about it
even existing and so restrained the
guitar
got back into that um wrote this is so
cliche but since we weren't doing shows
a lot i had time so i like wrote a pilot
so that's cool
learned got me some what is it final
draft learned about how to character
descriptions took
classes on how to do it so that's cool
yeah and then just like lots of therapy
anyone else do that that was i did a lot
of like oh awareness
you know like there's a lot of i'm aware
now so that's good that's what i've been
doing and i can
do a few songs now i can play a few
songs is there something anyone has
narrowed down in their life on that note
of like is there something like oh i
could completely do without this this is
something i thought i needed
in my life but now that i don't have it
oh a space
space and clothes space you don't need
just to live in
a big place i don't think just the i
have a one bedroom and i'm like oh i
just need this
one room like i'm always just in my
living room how about you guys
i think other people's approval i feel
like on the other end
i'm going out doing all kinds of
different outfits i'm gonna do my hair
differently i'm like already deciding
like am i getting tattoos maybe we do
this like i'm just like ready to
to go live yesterday so i feel like i'm
gonna be taking
more risks i think fashion wise because
i would always be like
this is not what people have been used
to seeing me in so it'll be a transit no
we're not doing that anymore man this is
a bummer everyone became a better person
learned a
certain ways i became really like way
worse like i realized i can't live
without target
[Music]
how would that target like a good amount
of time during the pandemic and i'm
talking about
early when we when it was like no stay
at home like don't go out unless it is
absolutely east central i'm like but i
want to smell a candle
you're like i was at target yeah so your
pitch is to close every small business
and that's what i learned is i don't
need small businesses i need
stores packed full of people how about
you moses
i think personal space of like i need
this time to be alone i think i need
less of it still some of it is
healthy but i don't need as much as i
thought
you had your fill yeah i'm like oh yeah
yeah none of this is like uh you're not
happy unless you could share it with
someone
and that little sweet thing yeah i get
that i heard and then the last thing
before we all cry
if you could change one feature
about zoom today you ha and it goes
across the board
what would it be should never have
yourself you yes
i don't want the self you ever i don't
care i don't want to see it
leave me alone i would change the mics i
don't like that
when one person speaks it cancels one
other person out i would change
it seems like the system operates on one
major mic if that makes sense
i would i would change that mike
okay yeah the mic the sound on zoom
that's a good one
especially but especially if you're
doing stand-up
you know if every anybody of all we've
all done zoom on stand up
it sucks it's like i didn't realize
until i listened back after like my
first show
when they're still laughing they can't
hear anything that you're saying like
you're completely knocked off the sound
because their laughter like dominates
your ten steps
way too close to my going
[Laughter]
i was watching one of jackie's stream
and someone was was coughing yeah zoom
comedy is when the laugh
actually becomes a heckle like
definitely we had that a few times where
i was like all right we get you're
enjoying the show but can you do it more
quietly
like that would be cool yeah exactly
jackie what would you pick
i would add a button where the host can
automatically
un like require video to turn on like i
would love to just turn
video on when people when people are
hidden i want to see what they're doing
behind closed doors
and i would love to just be like beep
and then everybody is revealed oh that
would be
what a powerful that would be what is it
i want that i know i'm this is
entertaining for me
this is entertaining yeah all right
all right okay so invasion of privacy is
what we selected
i would pick uh one end meeting button
not the second end meeting that are you
sure you have to
yeah over click because people have
picked their face of like
all right thank you guys so much for
doing the show my name is moses storm
we'll be back
oh totally i hate that thing where
you're like
it's so unattractive you want to it's
cute you want to like a good
cute end everything ends that way from
happy hours to these shows to like
meetings just like some of them and you
never remember that you have to do that
it's always like you click the leave
meeting and you're like oh yeah i gotta
do this
ugh your eyes wander and it looks weird
are you trying to leave on a joke and
then it bombs and you're like all right
let me find that
uh jackie where can people find you just
go to instagram
jackie comedy yeah and then there's
outdoor show coming up
if people are in the bay area yeah for
folks uh it's in half moon bay it's on
april 21st seven o'clock it is called
the new abnormal comedy show
at the san benito house cantina in half
moon bay
that's fine at zeta have you got both
podcasts honesty with z
just friends and then upload right and
upload yeah and if they want to check me
out on social media it's zaynab johnson
z-a-i-n-a-b johnson
that's great then natalie you are
selling water pills
yes for your new extreme diet yeah you
can get water pills
at my instagram at natdogcatdog
and you can check out my podcast called
hidden mickeys
yeah and then of course there's oh am i
special
nate on netflix yes thank you so much
should definitely watch that
thank you guys so much for doing the
show this is a lot of fun i'm glad we
all
got to talk yes thanks for having me
yeah thank you nice to meet you jackie
good to see you thank you natalie
good to see you natalie moses that's
gonna do it for us here at moses and
friends thank you so much for watching
the show
subscribe to the channel if you aren't
already and we'll see you next time
good night
[Music]
who's up with natalie the whole time
he's still here
sorry that's in the chat yep that's in
the chat getting that in the chat
leave the meeting eight buttons second
button
now you're still on those [ __ ] now
you're still on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
three
she made a piece
[Music]
kids
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
dance
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
three
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you